Accessing array elements
is straightforward.
You can access a particular element
by referring to its row and
column number inside
the square brackets.
The first integer over here
denotes to the row number and
the second integer denotes
to the column number.
Let's see which element do
we get at position 3,2.
Observe that the element we get
actually belongs to the fourth row and
the tall column, but note that the row
and the column indexing start from zero.
Hence if you want an element of
the fourth row and tall column,
you pass the parameter as we did,
that is 3,2.
Now let's do some interesting stuff,
accessing elements and ranges.
If I would want to access
elements from first
through third column in the zeroed row,
here is how I would do it.
This operation is called slicing,
as explained before using data frame.
Let's read out this slicing operation.
For the 0 through,
get values from first through third
column excluding the third column.
Now let's run this.
So here's the output.
For the 0 through, first through the
third column excluding the third column.
This was just column slicing.
We can combine row and column slicing
and get a subset of the array.
If I would like to access the top
left corner of the array,
I would do this as follows.
We can combine row and column slicing
and get the subset of the array.
Here is the top left corner,
which has elements at position 0,
0, 0, 1, 1, 0, and 1, 1.
One last interesting thing in slicing,
which I would like to
bring in front of you.
You see a lot of numbers over here,
so let's break it down and read it.
The three number separated by the colon,
this is not accessing the tall access.
But a slicing of the form,
n is to m is to t,
will give you values in the range n
before m, but in steps of size t,
hence this statement will give
you values of the column 0.
Skip the values of the column one, and
then give the values of the column 2.
Let's run this.
As explained, you get the 0, and
the second column with all the rows.
Seems like magic, right?